it's election day 2020 we examine the
last minute polls
trump and biden make their last minute
cases and we examine the left's plans if
joe biden is god forbid elected i'm ben
shapiro this is the ben shapiro show the
ben shapiro show is sponsored by
expressvpn why haven't you gotten a vpn
yet visit expressvpn.com
slash ben we will bring you all the
latest news the polling
in the end all the polls mean nothing
the only true poll is election day and
here here's my prediction pain
we'll get to that in just one second
first what if there were a company that
gave you amazing deals every day could
save you
lots and lots of money you know one of
the places you're spending a lot of
money right now
is in fact on your cell phone coverage
you're spending a lot of money on that
cell phone bill you don't have to do
that you should be getting the same cell
phone coverage with pure talk it's a
veteran-run wireless company think of
ats but much better they understand what
it means to serve
verizon a t t t-mobile if you're with
them you're overpaying pure and simple
pure talk
can easily save you over 400 bucks a
year listen this is all you need a
limited talk
text two gigs of data for just 20 bucks
a month and if you go over on data usage
they don't charge you for it which is
great
because really right now you are being
sold unlimited data you're not using
unlimited data but you're paying for
unlimited data which is really dumb it's
like buying all the seats on an airplane
so you can sit in one seat
bad move instead switch over to pure
talk it's the easiest decision
you will make today you can keep your
phone and your number or get great deals
on the latest iphones
and android grab that mobile phone dial
pound 250 say ben shapiro when you do
you save fifty percent off your first
month of service style pound two five
zero
say keyword ben shapiro pure talk is
simply smarter wireless down dial pound
two five zero say keyword ben shapiro
okay
so on the day of the election where
do we stand now i i sense a lot of
nervousness
on the left i think that nervousness is
a good indicator for the right it's also
a bad indicator for the right so it's a
good indicator in the sense that
the left being nervous means they don't
think that this election is out of reach
for trump
which is good i mean if they were that
confident if they thought that they were
going to walk away
with this thing that'd probably be a bad
sign but at the same time the fact that
they're nervous this time where they
were not last time means that the left
is going to get out and vote which means
if you're a conservative
here's your reminder get out and vote
and do it right now get out and vote
take three of your friends take five
your friends take ten of your friends if
you're in a swing state particularly
get out and vote all of these swing
states are in margin of error
all of them okay what's weird is that
nationally this is not a close election
and all the national polling biden is up
anywhere from seven to ten points
on the state level in the swing states
this is an extraordinarily close
election
a very very very close election now i'm
going to read you the real clear
politics pull averages
right now from the swing states and i'm
going to give you which key states to
watch tonight because they're going to
be some early indicators of where the
election is going
again the scenarios basically at this
point are
trump narrow victory biden narrow
victory biden blowout there's no
scenario here with the trump blowout
trump could theoretically do really well
in the electoral college as well as last
time he's not going to flip in all
likelihood any of the states
that hillary clinton won last time to
the red column nevada
and nevada and uh and for example
minnesota
probably are out of reach for trump but
he could
hold on to most of the states he won
last time and still win all he needs to
do is win all the states he won last
time and he can still lose michigan and
wisconsin
and he can still win the election that
is his most likely path to victory so
let's talk for a second about where
these state polls stand in the real
clear politics polling average
florida the real clear politics polling
average has biden up
0.9 which means it's even right that
means it's even
now having moved it down to florida i
can tell you the enthusiasm for trump in
florida is extraordinary i mean off the
charts large
and enthusiasm from the hispanic
community in florida is extremely large
there are a lot of
cuban expatriates a lot of venezuelan
expatriates which is becoming a larger
and larger vote a lot of brazilian
expatriates a lot of whom
sort of remember the battle days of
socialism in these various countries or
left-wing rule in places like brazil
and they think to themselves yeah i'm
not so hot on that it also turns out
that
one of the unfortunate facts about
translation from english to spanish or
fortunate
in this case for purposes of accuracy is
that the same word that biden was using
in his advertising to say that he was
going to be progressive
that word the uh the word that is used
in spanish and
forgive me my spanish is not good but
this i know the word in spanish for
progressive is the same as the word for
socialist
so when joe biden was advertising about
how progressive he was going to be
it was being translated into the spanish
ad says oh amugo chavez which is really
not a great look
okay so i think that he's going to win
florida but florida is extremely
extremely competitive
i went to vote in florida last week
there was a big line it was the middle
of the
it was the middle of the day on a monday
and there was a fairly long line i had
to wait 35 40 minutes to vote
uh where i was voting okay other
battleground states
north carolina trump is up 0.2 percent
anyone's dead even
now here's one thing that is true
nationally and particularly in these
swing states it looks like trump has a
lot of momentum
in virtually all of the swing states
trump has closed the gap so
there was a wide gap in florida for
biden
as very recently there's a wide gap for
biden in north carolina as of recently
there's a much wider gap for biden and
pennsylvania as of recently
right now biden and trump are within
margin of error in pennsylvania
according to that real clear politics
polling average
here are the last five polls in
pennsylvania hey insider advantage
had trump up two in pennsylvania nbc
news marist had biden up five in
pennsylvania
trafalgar had trump up two right
trafalgar is uh skewing very heavily
pro-trump they were the ones who called
it last time
and they're using a basic sort of
different voter waiting model
trying to tease out the shy trump voter
rasmussen had biden up three in
pennsylvania susquehanna today has
trump up one in pennsylvania so what
that ends up at is is dead even
right that is margin of error when when
the real politics polling average put
somebody
within two points basically it's a
toss-up state so that means that
we are florida's a toss-up state north
carolina is a toss-up state
pennsylvania is a toss-up state michigan
the margin has come down
for biden the margin was up at seven or
eight points just about a week ago
and now that margin has dropped fairly
dramatically
really in the last couple of weeks the
real politics polling average in
michigan
had biden up nine it had biden up nine
just about
two weeks ago not even two weeks a week
ago biden was up nine in that real club
politics polling average
now biden is up four in that real clear
politics polling average so trump is
closing in the gap
and fast in michigan as well although
that one again
trump would really have to exceed
expectations to win michigan in ohio
trump is now up in the real
politics polling average in arizona
biden and trump are dead even
the real clear politics polling average
had biden with a wide lead just a couple
of days ago
just a few days ago biden was up five
points in arizona
now they're dead even there's that even
in the real
politics polling average okay texas
trump is up at 1.2
it's widely expected that trump is going
to win texas anyway nevada
biden is only up by 2.2 in nevada so
that one is close to margin of error
georgia trump is up one
that one should be a lot wider so
there's two ways to slice this one is
there a lot of states that trump should
be walking away with that are way too
close to call
the other is that all the states that
biden needs to walk away with are also
too close to call
which means that when you look at the
final analysis of the polling and
good news guys after tomorrow after
tonight ain't no more pulling talk
nobody cares because the polls are done
right if you look at the polls right now
the polls would not have to be wrong for
biden to win
320 electoral votes or for trump to win
300 electoral votes the polls would not
have to be wrong for any of that to
happen
remember polls are a margin of error
business if you get it within the margin
of error your poll was right it doesn't
actually have to call
who won the poll if again that is within
a point or two it doesn't matter the
poll did a good job
so the election is really really close
which is why you need to get out and you
need to vote and you need to do it
right now now the media are setting up a
post-election
sort of conundrum for the american
people which is if trump wins
they've already set up this narrative
with voter suppression
voter suppression is not a thing on the
right there's a lot of talk about voter
fraud
okay there's the possibility of people
attempting voter fraud there has been no
evidence of
widespread voter fraud in the tens of
thousands or hundreds of thousands the
possibility of somebody exploiting the
system does exist
that exists in every system where you
have 160 million people doing anything
but do i think that this election is
going to come down to either voter fraud
or voter suppression i know for a fact
it's not coming down to voter
suppression because we have the highest
rates of voting in american history
right now
and not in terms of the overall rate but
in terms of the number of actual votes
we're going to have more votes in this
election than any time in american
history
before election day we had over 90
million ballots cast
in states like texas more ballots have
been cast before election day than were
cast all the way through election day
last time around
so we're going to blow out whatever
record number of votes were cast in the
last election there is
no widespread voter suppression people
are not stopping people from voting it's
not a thing there have been lawsuits
filed to determine what constitutes a
legally
a legally cast ballot that is not the
same thing as voter suppression if i sue
because i think that you are casting a
ballot without fulfilling the legal
obligations
that's not called voter suppression that
is called enforcement of statutory law
and the courts will interpret that and
many of these lawsuits that have been
attempting to for example
discount drive through balloting in
texas have been invalidated by like a
bush judge a bush judge
invalidated that lawsuit so all the talk
about voter suppression is nonsense
you'll notice the media are pushing the
voter suppression
angle extremely hard because they're
always looking for another reason
for democrats not being responsible for
their own loss
this is something that that i don't
really see republicans doing very often
looking for an excuse for why their
candidate lost if republicans lose
i think that what you're going to see is
republicans being upset republicans
believing correctly that the media put
their thumb not just their thumb their
entire arm not just their entire arm
their entire body on the scale in favor
of joe biden
and i think republicans will be angry
about that and i think they'll be right
to be angry about that but there's not
going to be any excuse making
in a large measure about how the system
itself was deeply corrupt and needs to
be torn down at the root
there's not going to be talk about how
we need to quash americans fundamental
freedoms
in order to ensure that our candidates
win that's something only the left does
in 2016 we had the intelligence
apparatus mobilized against trump
post-election right i mean this is now
pretty clear that james comey and
company were actually
using nefarious means in order to target
members of the trump administration
right people like michael flynn
that the we've seen the democratic party
get into the business of trying to
regulate the living hell out of social
media and or pressure social media with
threats of regulation
so they will prevent the dissemination
of information and they were successful
they were successful at bullying twitter
and facebook into not covering things
about joe biden that joe biden found
unflattering
you saw democrats talking about
reconstituting the senate adding states
you talked
they're still talking about getting rid
of the filibuster they're talking about
getting rid of the electoral college
packing the supreme court when democrats
lose in other words they see this as a
problem with the system
when republicans lose they generally see
it as a problem with the candidate when
democrats lose it's the system
and or that 45 of americans they think
are just terrible people
when republicans lose it's generally
about the candidate
it may be about people in the media not
covering things properly
that asymmetry means that democrats are
constantly pushing for the thing they're
always pushing for which is systemic
change which is exactly the sort of
thing that you should be afraid of
because the systems of the united states
are in fact quite good a thing to
remember this election day as with every
election day
for virtually all of human history human
beings could not choose their own
leaders
for virtually all of human history
people could not vote to change a party
in power for a party out of power
for virtually all of human history
people lived in poverty
people lived on the on the verge of
death and for billions of people the
world over all of this is still true
america is a damned incredible country
and if you're solution
to your candidate losing is we need to
tear down the entire system
that is because you're doing something
wrong if your solution to your candidate
losing is
we need to infringe on americans
fundamental freedom you're doing
something wrong this is what i'm fearful
of if the left wins today
i'm fearful of the democrats going along
with that program to tear down those
fundamental freedoms because they see
those things as
obstacles to their agenda either those
things are tools for them the electoral
college is good when obama wins right
if texas flip flips to to biden today
the electoral college will be good again
but when those things cut against their
agenda those things become bad
democrats are instrumentalists about the
system they don't believe in the system
itself
they're instrumentalist about it if the
system helps them it is good if the
system does not help them it is bad and
it ought to be torn out and that's what
you ought to be afraid of that's why
democrats should not be put in charge of
the system because they don't actually
believe in the system they don't
actually believe in the institutions
they make excuses for why hillary
clinton lost rather than just saying she
was a crap candidate who deserved to
lose
and the american people chose against
her instead of that they decided that
they were going to start tearing away at
the fundamental fabric of american
freedoms and american institutions
that's going to continue a pace
whether biden is elected or not but if
biden's elected he's now in charge of
dismantling a system
that elected him to office and i don't
think that he'll be shy about that we'll
get to that
in just one second first let's talk
about the quality of your clothing
so now i used to be one of those guys
who would just go buy like a generic
t-shirt and then after like three washes
it would fall apart it would look crappy
it just doesn't look good and more and
more these days because many of us are
working at home and we're wearing more
casual stuff you need a great t-shirt
that looks fantastic
every time it comes out of the wash this
is why i love i love the clothing from
cuts
you don't really need to wear a tie for
your zoom meeting but sweatpants and
your go-to gym tee don't really feel
right either
cut clothing it's the perfect solution
to your work from home wardrobe at
confusion
cuts is the best in the world at making
technical apparel for the sport of
business
they're t-shirts polos hoodies they have
enough quality and style to wear in the
office on a date anywhere in between you
don't have to choose between a classic
look
and a modern feel after four years of
development cuts has finally released
their new polos and hoodies
the new pika polo was designed in los
angeles with cuts custom engineered pika
pro fabric that keeps you fitted for the
daily work grind a happy hour escape
everything in between cuts new hoodies
they're made with their custom hyperloop
french terry fabric they were designed
with comfort in mind and lasting
structure for the long haul i basically
only wear cut
t-shirts at this point because they are
so good cuts is loved by your favorite
athletes entrepreneurs
even magnificent humans like me it seems
like everyone is wearing cuts
these days get 15 off your first order
by going cutsclothing.com
shapiro again that's cutsclothing.com
for 15
off the only shirt worth wearing go
check them out right now
cutsclothing.com
shapiro okay so a lot of people are
paying attention to the national polling
tonight that's pretty much worthless
there are a couple reasons why it's
pretty much worthless
if trump comes within four points in the
national polling he has a shot at
winning
if he loses by eight it's gonna be a
foregone conclusion at that point that
he probably
not probably he will lose if he if he's
down eight points in the popular vote
he's gonna lose now it's also true that
if there is a shy trump effect i was
talking about this with uh
one by our fellow daily wire talents
cassie dillon
she was pointing out that if there is a
shy trump effect
you know people who are are voting trump
and not telling pollsters they're gonna
vote trump
that's actually most likely to show up
in national polling not state level
polling i tend to agree with this
the reason being if you live in
california you live in new york no way a
pollster calls you up
and asks you about who you're voting for
you're like absolutely trump because the
social consequences of voting for trump
in a place like california or new york
or massachusetts
or illinois right in very heavily
populated democratic states
the shy trump vote could really be a
thing so you could see
a heavy overestimate of biden's margin
of victory
in the popular vote based on that shy
trump effect particularly in major
cities and blue areas
around the country but as 537 says
or 538 rather nate silver's organization
if
donald trump comes within four points of
joe biden
if he's three if he's three points down
to joe biden in the national vote he'll
win
basically there's a 57 shot that if he
is within three points in the national
popular vote
then donald trump wins so
trump does not need to close the gap the
entire way he does not need to win the
popular
vote now with that said obviously the
the
national polling is bad for trump
according to yahoo on the eve of what
threatens to be the most contentious and
potentially confusing election day in
modern memory
democratic presidential nominee joe
biden retains a double-digit lead over
president trump in that final yahoo news
at yougov poll of the 2020 campaign
it's a 10-point margin that's more than
three times as large as hillary
clinton's final polling advantage in
2016. yet most voters 51 expect trump to
refuse to concede if he loses
more than three quarters 77 worry that
violence will break out
in the coming days okay this has all
been prepped by the media okay
when i talk about the the media being a
target that people should should focus
in on
the media's behavior over the last four
years has fundamentally foreclosed the
possibility that you should trust them
ever again
seriously there needs to be an
alternative media source you look to i'm
not saying never turn on cnn again
although that'd be fine
i'm saying that if you're going to watch
cnn you absolutely need to watch
another source you cannot take it for
granted that these objective news
sources so-called objective news sources
are providing you objective news they
absolutely are not
the narrative that trump is going to
refuse to concede if he loses the
election like loses it clearly
not that it gets litigated in
pennsylvania and then he refuses to
concede but that he loses georgia he
loses texas and then he's sitting there
being like i'm never giving up like
that's not going to happen
okay that's a media created narrative
trump
should just say if i lose clearly of
course i'm out but i'm gonna have to
make sure that all the legally cast
ballots that are that are cast
are counted and then if i lose of course
i leave right i mean that's obvious that
is true
mike pence has said it and other members
of the cabinet have said it
as far as the worry that violence is
going to break out in the coming days
who do you think is responsible for that
violence
right here's here is why people are
worried about violence seriously the
reason people are worried about violence
is because the democrats in the media
have crafted a narrative the narrative
is perfectly obvious
okay that narrative is that if if donald
trump wins
it must be some form of voter
suppression it must be
some form of corruption the system is
fundamentally broken
he's gonna be a dictator for life and
therefore you should be out in the
streets
the media have been promoting this the
idea that it's right-wingers who are
promoting violence in the streets it is
not right
it's not right honest to god if donald
trump loses i do not think you're gonna
see right-wing violence in the street
i'll eat my words if that turns out not
to be true but i i do not see the
evidence that right-wingers are gonna go
out in the street and start burning down
stores and breaking into cvs if donald
trump loses tonight
it's only the left that's been doing
that and the the overt attempt by the
media
to twist street violence into a
republican phenomenon is
completely insane and also it's amazing
how gullible the american people are
about this
there's a poll that came out in the
middle of the rioting in kenosha showing
that a plurality of americans were more
worried about white supremacist rioting
in america's major cities then black
lives matter which is totally crazy
okay because you can believe the media
or you can believe your own eyes but the
problem is when the media
are your eyes there is no way for you to
believe otherwise okay we're going to
get to
more of this more of the preparations
for violence for what's coming after
in just one second first let us talk
about
how hard it is to find excellent
excellent employees so i am back
in los angeles today for our election
night broadcast
and you know it reminded me that i have
a lot of great employees here in los
angeles it also reminded me
that i have some not so great employees
i mean just to be perfectly frank
about this i mean some of them actually
i brought with me from florida but
some of them they could i'm not going to
name
any names i'm not going to say that like
you know
pablo could have been quicker with the
coffee or the nica could have been
faster on the hair or anything
i i'm not just gonna name names i'm not
gonna say that you know folks like
cassie
it could be a little bit less i don't
know obtrusive about their their
instagram talk all i'm going to say is
that there's a lot of room at this
company and all other companies for
upgrading your employment staff and this
is why you should check out ziprecruiter
right now ziprecruiter can be tried for
free at ziprecruiter.com
dailywire when you post a job on zip
recruiter it gets sent out to over 100
job sites with just one click then
zip recruiter's powerful matching
technology finds people with the right
skills and experience
for your job and it actively invites
them to apply so you get qualified
candidates fast
it's no wonder four out of five
employers who post unzip recruiter get a
quality candidate within the very first
day right now you can try zip recruiter
for free
at ziprecruiter.com dailywire that is
ziprecruiter.com
d-a-i-l-y-w-i-r-e try it again for free
ziprecruiter.com slash daily wire zipper
crew is indeed
the smartest way to hire and uh i would
just be remiss if i did not mention that
i also that nick
fell within my eye line today so he will
also be mentioned in the zip recruiter
ad just as you know just a slap at nick
because
it had it had to be done okay so as we
as we move toward the election you can
see this narrative being set up
and the narrative is that if the
election goes the wrong way democrats
will tear down the system
also if the election goes the right way
democrats will tear down the system so
it seems as though
almost it doesn't matter how the
election goes democrats and media and
the left would like to tear down the
system
that's exciting stuff twitter was
pushing today a piece from yahoo news
australia in their twitter trends i'm
sure that there were so many people
who were aiming their their clickers
over to they were aiming their mouse
over to the yahoo news australia site
that twitter just had to feature it
they just had to feature the piece
because so many people visit yahoo news
australia
the piece is called the controversial
u.s electoral college explained
oh it's controversial now is it so this
left-wing talking point that the
electoral college you know the system by
which we devise our presidents and have
done so
for more than two centuries that that is
um that is controversial
that's not just being promoted by
twitter willy-nilly josh shapiro
no relation thank god who is the
attorney general of the state of
pennsylvania
he tweeted out if the votes are added up
in pennsylvania trump is going to lose
that's why he's working overtime to
subtract as many votes as possible from
this process
for the record he's owned six against us
in court we've protected voting rights
now
ignore the noise vote okay so just going
to point out here
that um that is paving the way for
violence it is if all the votes are
added up in p.a trump will lose
that's the attorney general of the state
of pennsylvania charged with enforcing
the law
in the state of pennsylvania saying that
if his candidate doesn't win if joe
biden does not win
it's because somebody cheated that's
dangerous stuff
what's amazing is that the media refused
to acknowledge that it's dangerous stuff
when it comes from the left
they just keep talking about voter
suppression and trump talking about
voter fraud and all this kind of stuff
when your entire mainstream media is
telling you the election is not legit if
trump wins
what do you think is going to be the
predictable result especially in a
country where
the vast majority of political violence
that we have seen
over the course of the last six months
has been left-wing political violence in
the streets
why do you think these businesses are
boarding up our business out here in la
is boarded up today why do you think
that is you think we're boarding up
because we think that the trump caravan
folks gonna come beat down our doors if
trump were to lose
according to axios america's cities are
bracing for violence as soon as tomorrow
driving the news landmarks stores and
restaurants in new york washington d.c
and other cities are boarding up their
front doors
in fear that election day will bring
another blow to their businesses many of
which are already reeling from the
pandemic and damage from photos
why it matters the country's election to
outcome could lead to civil unrest no
matter who wins
people all over the country are
preparing for the worst see that's the
funny part too is that if biden wins
you could see celebratory riots in the
streets it's rioting for all seasons out
here
in the blue cities and uh i'm enjoying
the fact that many of these blue
cities are many of these businesses
they're putting up the board on their
on their stores during the black lives
matter riots they put up
blm black owned business on the boards
like please don't rob us of course it
doesn't help
at all now they're putting up anti-trump
crap on their businesses so that
everybody knows that you shouldn't rob
their store
because they don't like trump either
okay but let's be real about this the
only people who are looking to rob
stores and loot things
those are not donald trump voters they
ain't
okay so post-election that is the threat
okay this is is everything crystallized
trump
is not a threat to the system i know you
keep hearing from the media that trump
is the threat to the system he's been
president for four years explain how
he's threatened the system
please i'm waiting seriously he has not
overturned the will of the supreme court
he's obeyed their law he's obeyed their
rulings he has not overthrown the will
of congress
he has not used executive orders in
nearly as expansive ways as his
predecessor barack obama did
he has not threatened the press nobody's
in jail because of trump hey barack
obama actually put journalists in jail
donald trump has not done that donald
trump has started no new foreign wars
donald trump has been a far less
obtrusive governmental presence in your
life
than anybody from the democratic party
was or will be in the aftermath of the
election
because just recognize that after the
election all of the incentives for
democrats are to crack down hard
particularly with regard to covid i
already made my prediction on covet
yesterday i think what will happen is
that we will hit the top of the curve
in december in terms of number of
infections late november december this
is what the scientists are suggesting
and then by the time the inauguration it
will already be on the way
and if joe biden is made president it
won't matter he'll still do national
lockdowns he'll still do masking and
then he'll claim credit
after the curve has already started to
come down the other side and then the
media will go right along with it
which is exactly what they did with
andrew cuomo right andrew cuomo only
started
implementing all the masking measures
after the curve had already hit the peak
and then they credited him as though he
had fixed everything which was absurd on
its face
in just a second we'll get to the final
campaign points being made
by all of the various sides and again
politics very often comes down to the
stupidest iterations
of what are actually very profound ideas
so we'll see that in action
as both parties rally to the end trump
has been visiting pennsylvania a lot
biden is in pennsylvania he's been
deploying barack obama to florida
those those are i think the two key
states tonight by the way if you really
had to ballpark it
you have to say that pennsylvania and
florida are the two key states if trump
wins florida he still has to win
pennsylvania if biden wins florida the
election's over
that's gonna be your first indicator so
if you're watching our coverage tonight
what you should at dailywire.com because
we're doing it all night long we have
surprises
special guests and amazing announcements
like really truly incredible
announcements for
what we're going to be doing in the next
year is pretty great heading over to
daily wear at night
but florida is going to be the first
indicator is how things are going to go
tonight
and we're going to get some more of this
in just one second first let us talk
about the fact that if you've ever owned
a car
and not at least owned a car and you've
got in your car in a bit of a scrape
car repairs can cost you an absolute
damn fortune and i remember
i had a baby blue and i got married i
had a baby baby blue 2006
ford mustang gt convertible my wife
hated it because it really messed up her
hair when we were dating she hated it
now i have
of course the dad car i have a honda
odyssey um and
love it love it love not the same well
in any case
my wife uh made the unfortunate mistake
of driving that ford mustang gt
up onto a planter outside of our house
like an actual planter in our front yard
so the car was up off the ground and i
like an idiot i was like i will get it
down
so i put it in reverse and promptly
pulled it down off the planter
shaking the transmission loose from the
car that cost a damn fortune
i wish at that point i'd had car shield
because car shield allows you not to
worry about these sorts of things car
shield offers a wide range of protection
plans that can save you thousands for a
covered repair
that means that check engine light is a
lot less scary when it comes on you have
the freedom to choose your favorite
mechanic or dealership to do the work
car shield gets the rest taken care of
even if your car breaks down while
you're traveling
the choice of a repair shop is still up
to you on top of that no long-term
contracts or commitments payments are
flexible car shield plans are
customizable to your exact needs
car shield has helped over one million
drivers that's why they're america's at
number one auto protection company
i used to dread car repairs now i no
longer have to car shield
saves me go to car shield dot com slash
ben use codebend to save it 10
that's carshield.com use code ben a
deductible
may apply okay so everybody campaigning
to the end
president trump has been in michigan he
has been in pennsylvania
he's all over the place he has deployed
members of his family members of
cabinets places like arizona
trump's closing pitch is what his pitch
should have been all along
which is he has helped the economy he
has kept the country open we are in fact
in the midst
of a historically good economic recovery
from a historic low because of the
coveted shutdowns that were necessary
at the beginning when we didn't know
what we were doing but now our accounts
are productive and unnecessary
here is president trump talking about
how under him
the economy grew at the fastest rate
ever under my leadership
our economy is now growing at the
fastest rate
ever recorded in the history of our
country
[Music]
33.1
33.1 we created a record 11.4 million
jobs in the last five months
okay so that obviously is true and that
would have been a great campaign
right i wish that we had more of that
trump on the stump throughout the
campaign
trump also pointed out his
accomplishments right he said we have
great new supreme court justices this of
course is also true
we're going to have we just put a great
one on amy
three
[Applause]
supreme court justices and whatever
happened with biden
he was going to say you know is he going
to pack the court he just keeps tapping
maybe he's smarter than we think
keeps tapping it along and who are the
people he's going to put on he was
supposed to say who is but
you cannot vote for him if he doesn't
tell you about packing the court
okay so that that is trump's closing
pitch mike pence of course made the same
pitch
he points out that under president trump
we've stood for religious freedom again
this is the thing about trump's record
trump's record is quite good as i've
pointed out a thousand times on this
program already if you just separated
off all the things that people don't
like about trump's personality from the
stuff he's gotten done
he'd win in a walk that poll from gallup
showing 56 percent of americans
say they are better off now than they
were four years ago which is indeed the
highest percentage for any president
in the last 30 years that should be a
foregone conclusion he wins a lot of
this is just a personality
issue here's mike pence pointing out the
record
under president donald trump we've stood
for that first freedom religious freedom
strong
we restored the conscience rights of
doctors and nurses and it was president
donald trump
who ended the assault on the little
sisters of the poor
and the supreme court made it permanent
okay mike pence was right about that he
also pointed out at this rally that
donald trump is in favor of more
fracking one of the reasons that you've
seen the polls close so fast in
pennsylvania
is because of joe biden saying in that
last debate that he
was going to end the oil industry we're
going to transition away from the oil
industry here's pence going after that
men and women of michigan no matter what
joe biden and kamala harris saying right
now you can take it to the bank
joe biden and the democratic party are
going to try and abolish fossil fuels
close down the oil industry ban fracking
but we're not going to let it happen
we're going to have more fracking
more american energy more energy
independence
for this generation and for generations
to come
when we re-elect president donald trump
for four more years
on a policy level these are all 60 40
propositions in favor of the republicans
pence also pointing out that republicans
aren't interested
in defunding the police joe biden has
said he's also not interested in
defunding the police there's only one
problem
he's talked openly about shifting
funding away from police which
technically speaking is defunding the
police here's pence president donald
trump i'll make your promise
we're not gonna defund the police not
now not
ever we're gonna back the blue and we're
gonna back the blue for four more years
okay so that is the contrast of visions
meanwhile
joe biden's entire campaign has been
that donald trump is a blade upon the
land and when removed everything will be
solved so yesterday he campaigned
as alternatively your dad the pope and
god
that was his actual campaign yesterday
he tweeted out three separate tweets
that sort of laid this out one
he suggested that he was going to treat
you like a member of his family which is
the last
thing that i want i do not want him
treating me like a member of his family
okay because i don't want any politician
treating me like a member of their
family frankly if i were gonna have a
politician treat me like a member of his
family
biden's not a bad guy to do it because
then i could pick up bags of cash for no
reason except my family name and ukraine
and
kazakhstan and china wouldn't have to
know anything about those countries
could just kind of jet set there
and pick up giant bags of cash that'd be
fun but he said he was going to treat us
like members of our family
of his family which i don't want i don't
want these people anywhere near my
family god bless and keep the tsar far
far away from us
and then he tweeted out i started this
campaign saying we were in a battle for
the soul of this nation and i believe
that even more deeply today
make no mistake it's a battle we can and
will win okay so if you believe that
your soul is going to be saved by a
geriatric politician who's shifted every
major position he's ever held
while corruptly using his office to
allow his friends and family to benefit
from it
if that guy's gonna save your soul get a
little god in your life and then find
and then joe biden's like well i am god
good news so here was his final tweet
i'm not gonna shut down the country i'm
not gonna shut down the economy i'm
gonna shut down the virus yeah bullcrap
okay this is wish casting for morons if
you're you're such a dupe that you think
that this guy's gonna save you
your life is on the line and joe biden's
gonna save you donald trump is a threat
to your life
he's gonna come to your house deep at
night he's gonna take those
those orange hands and wrap them around
your throat like you're an idiot i don't
know what to tell you
okay but but the entire biden campaign
is specifically and only
about what a bad person donald trump is
because on policy
they don't got a lot on policy nobody
likes their policies
right so here's biden's biden's closing
campaign again was donald trump is a
very bad man who's bad and orange and
mean and bad and also bad and stupid
he knew in january how dangerous it was
and how many people could die and he
said
nothing he didn't say a thing to you me
or anybody else
he kept it secret he hid it from the
american people
he knew was worse than the flu he lied
to the american people he knew
it wasn't going to disappear he kept
telling us a miracle was coming
or maybe we should inject uh bleach into
our veins i mean whatever
god what a anyway okay so um he didn't
say he was they shouldn't check bleach
in your veins
he said very silly things during that
press conference about getting some
light in your body or something
it was more about injecting sunlight
frankly but none of that should be like
honestly
how about this how about instead of
focusing in on the dumb things that
trump says over the course of his
presidency you focus in
on the things that he has done as
president of the united states it is
also a lie by the way
that trump knew how bad kovid was even
bob woodward doesn't really allege that
donald trump quote unquote knew how bad
coveted was
nobody did anthony fauci in february was
suggesting everybody go about their
business
but according to joe biden in january
donald trump knew this was going to kill
hundreds of thousands of people into
nothing which is just crap
okay the the reason that joe biden has
to focus in on trump's personalities
again the policies of trump have been
successful
and two if you spend more than five
minutes watching joe biden you know two
things
one this guy is no transformational
savior of the united states
and two this guy ain't gonna be in
office long here's just a little bit of
joe biden over the last 24 hours
stumbling over his words because again
you can be you know maybe he'll be maybe
if he's elected
uh he will be competent through the
first four years of his administration i
tend to doubt it and i don't think that
that is a a rip
on everybody who's above a certain age i
think it's a rip on this guy
i've been watching this guy for a decade
i've been watching him since 2008 and
before because he's a senator before
that
the market decline in joe biden it's
very obvious which means that kamala
harris is going to be president here was
joe biden yesterday
stumbling and bumbling just throughout
the day
no other nation can matches we lead by
the
example of our power not just by the
power but by the power of our example
my son beau volunteered he had to give
up the seat of attorney general
and volunteer to go to iraq for a year
he won the bronze star the conspicuous
service medal
i'll be the first president who didn't
have an ivy league degree
in a long time well let me tell you
something
somehow this can't mean i didn't belong
okay i'm sorry
i'm sorry like that that is not a person
who is going to be serving
as president of the united states in
eight years i i doubt he'll be serving
as president of the united states
and four instead you're gonna get this
here's kamala harris talking yesterday
about getting rid of trump's tax bill
which by the way if you actually got rid
of trump's entire tax bill would raise
taxes on 80
of americans joe understands that when
they pass that tax bill benefiting the
top one percent and the biggest
corporations of america
causing us to deal with a two trillion
dollar deficit
that that wasn't about working people
and if we get done what we need to get
done
pennsylvania in the next 24 hours
joe and i are about to get rid of that
tax bill
all of the tax bill you're going to get
rid of you mean even the parts that cut
taxes for everybody
that person is who you're actually going
to end up with as as president
um when she was selected as vp i thought
that was such a gift to trump and it
just i don't think it was taken
advantage
sufficiently of by by the trump pens
campaign okay we'll get to more of this
in
just one second and then we'll get to
what things are going to look like
if god forbid trump loses what it looks
like in a post-trump era
because you can see where this is going
you can see where this is going the
threat is to the institutions and the
threat is from the left we'll get to
that in one second first
let's talk about something you can do
that's great for your family so i've
been encouraging
today people go out and vote and then
spend some time with your family because
it's much more important to spend time
with your family than it is to vote
it just is just in terms of your life it
is much more important
one great way that you can bring
families together rather than tearing
them apart through politics
is through a service called legacy box
it's a super simple mail and service to
have all your video tapes camcorder
tapes film reels pictures digitally
preserved
on a thumb drive at dvd or the cloud are
your family's memories trapped on an old
camcorder tape or a film reel
do you even have a vhs player anymore
the answer of course is not you do not
have a vcr so what you need to do is
translate all of those memories and you
need to put them in a digital format
that you can use
and that you can access legacy box is
doing this for my parents it's just
fantastic i cannot wait to see the
results when we get all those film reels
back
of my grandparents and we can finally
look at those for the first time in 30
years
legacy box is a way for you to easily
and affordably digitally preserve your
past the process from start to finish is
incredibly simple you pack and you send
their team digitizes everything by hand
and then you enjoy legacy box is the
world's largest digitizer of home movies
and photos they've helped over 850
000 families digitally preserve their
past get started future proofing your
memories today
so you can gather the family begin that
trip down at memory lane head on over to
legacybox.com
shapiro to get an incredible 40 off your
first order buy today take advantage of
this exclusive offer
send in when you are ready go to
legacybox.com save 40
while supplies last that is
legacybox.com
shapiro and we use that slash appear you
say 40 well supplies
last alrighty more coming up in one
second first as you may have noticed um
it's election day
okay it is urgent urgent that you go
down and vote
okay and then once you voted you stick
with us all day long
we have programming all day long and
this is an urgent election
what we are watching right now is i'm
going to discuss more in a moment is the
threat to our institutions our
fundamental freedoms
okay the the fact is that for the
democratic party
freedoms fundamental american philosophy
these are all obstacles to utopian
vision
of leveling that they see and kamal
harris put out a video yesterday in
which he explicitly said
that equality of outcome is the goal and
that anything that stands in the way of
equality of outcome is in fact inequity
okay that's just outright soft marxism
that's just all it is
and democrats are willing to make your
rights secondary
to all of their goals they had a choice
to make they could have stood with
american rights
and it would have made their program for
utopia a little bit harder to achieve
or they could have gone all the way with
the hard work left and they went all the
way to hard work left
that's what's at stake in this election
the direction of the country so you need
to go vote and then you need to tune
into dailywire.com
and you need to make sure that you watch
our programming all day long
right now 25 off all memberships the
code election
is our special election day deal our
election coverage starts at 3 p.m
eastern
12 p.m pacific time it's gonna go all
day
all the way until we either have a
winner or we don't have a winner we're
gonna go until as late as we can
possibly stand it's gonna be like 11
hours 12 hours i mean like
all day long also we have lots of
surprises for you coming up on tonight's
broadcast
so it starts at like 3 p.m eastern 12
p.m pacific and then
we do basically backstage all night to
cover everything we have election
cutaways to experts in the in the other
room who are covering the map
it's going to be great okay it's going
to be just fantastic and you're going to
want to stick with us
the entire time it'll be entertaining
all right hopefully there will be more
laughter than tears
you're going to watch all day and again
25 off with code election well you're at
it
you need to pick up a copy of my book
how to destroy america in three easy
steps
okay that book is not just relevant for
the election it is relevant
way beyond the election you know there's
a lot of education that needs to be done
particularly
particularly of america's young people
if you've got a kid who's in high school
if you are a kid in high school if
you're
if you're a young person in college
people ask me all the time what's the
best book to read that will give me like
a brief overview of american philosophy
in american history this is that book
and it's about why there are so many
people who want to tear away that
history tear away that philosophy
tear away key parts of american culture
go check out my book how to destroy
america in three easy steps
right now is a valuable read i'm very
proud of it and i think it's going to
impact a lot of people it already has
hundreds of thousands of people
have bought it so go check it out right
now you can pick it up at amazon or
barnesandnoble.com you're listening to
the largest fastest growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
alrighty so let's talk about the
institutions because this is really what
i want to talk about
because this is the battle the battle
isn't just about trump and biden
as you know when it comes to
personalities i have no
great love for any of these candidates
my view of politicians they are plumbers
i don't want to hear about their lives i
don't want to hear about what they do i
don't really care
i don't want to hang out with them i
spend too much time with them as it is
already the more time you spend with
politicians the more you realize that
they are the dumb ass kids
from your third grade class who picked
their boogers and ate them and there's
this great myth about american politics
that is the greatest wisest statesman
among us who make it in american
politics
uh i think that um we should let that
one go guys
frankly politics is veep it is not in
fact house of cards conspiracy theories
are generally wrong because they require
a baseline level of intelligence and
competence that simply does not exist
for the vast majority
of people who are elected to high office
okay with that said
what does protect you are your
constitutional rights what does protect
you are the institutions of the united
states
but those only work that only that only
works they only protect you if those
function properly so that means the
intelligence apparatus
only works to protect you if it
functions properly and is not
politicized
which is why i am deeply fearful that if
trump were to lose
the repoliticization of the intelligence
apparatus would be upon us
okay there is no question at this point
that the intelligence apparatus people
like peter strzok and james comey
was politicized in the early days of the
trump administration in the last days of
the obama administration there's just no
question about this
okay the evidence is now very clear that
whether or not the russia
gate investigation was properly
predicated and evidence suggests that it
probably was not that this was bad
information being funneled via the
hillary clinton campaign and fusion gps
two members of the fbi
in order to initiate an investigation
but even assuming that was done in good
faith
the quick turn from that too we are
going to use every means at our disposal
legal and otherwise
in order to fulfill our utopian fantasy
of donald trump as russian agent
that was a complete perversion of what
the intelligence agencies are supposed
to do and so it is no surprise today
that james comey was responsible for
overseeing much of this
posed in a biden-harris 2020 t-shirt
with a biden harris
coffee cup yeah we know james we know we
are fully aware that is the problem
you're claiming that you're gonna save
the intelligence apparatus from being
politicized by donald trump
you were there before trump and you were
a political actor then
we all know that james comey acted
politically in order to protect hillary
clinton
from criminal liability in her emails
case he actually had to rewrite the law
and add intent as an element of the law
in order to not prosecute hillary
clinton
and then he oversaw the fisa warrants
that were not legal against carter page
james comey was a political figure he
was a grandstanding political figure
he remains a grandstanding political
figure and he'll go back to being in the
government
if if joe biden wins people like him
well even if james comey has never
rehired
people like peter strzok the supposed
good soldiers who are overtly political
those people will be in charge of an
apparatus that is capable
of watching your every move or taking
out fisa warrants against you
okay the intelligence apparatus is going
to be repoliticized
the electoral college is gonna come
under fire so sally cohn
one of the ids of the democratic party
and she tweeted out whatever the outcome
tomorrow and then all capital letters
the electoral college is a horrible
racist regressive mechanism of
repressing democracy
and i just said it that way because it's
all in capital letters
yes i'm sure the electoral college is a
horrible racist regressive mechanism of
repressing democracy right the electoral
college will come
under fire right the senate will come
under fire you've already seen many
democrats saying the senate is unconstit
the senate is not unconstitutional as
un-american because montana has as many
votes as california
which is um sort of the point you may
have noticed
also the democrats are claiming that
they want to kill the filibuster
they're claiming that they want to add
states to the united states senate in
order to make it permanently democratic
and they've talked openly about quashing
the courts
there's no question that the democratic
party is going to push radically to the
left i mean bernie sanders is saying
this openly he says if joe biden wins
then biden and bernie and ayanna presley
and the squad and nohan omar and
alexander ocasio-cortez
the honorable alexandra ocasio-cortez
not aoc we can't say that anymore
the honorable congresswoman alexander
ocasio-cortez d-twitch
uh representative to leave bernie
sanders these are the people pushing
biden to the left and he's gonna go
along with it because this dude is not a
bulwark in favor of moderation
so our first task we made it clear
everybody's no great secret
our first task we got to defeat the
worst president the modern history
of this country number two we organize
our people to make sure that biden
becomes the most progressive president
since fdr
the assault on our institutions is going
to be overwhelming it's going to be an
assault on our freedoms because those
institutions protect our freedoms
there will be assaults on freedom of
speech there will be a push from the
left over the coming years
for for hate speech regulation for an
attempt to stop people from speaking
freely
there will be a push on the left against
religious freedom for the idea that if
you're a religious person in america you
cannot operate your business as you see
fit because they have social priorities
that take priority that they take first
place they will come after guns because
they've said they're coming after guns
joe biden said they're coming after guns
he said he put beta o'rourke
in charge of coming after your guns okay
they are coming after all of the
institutions fundamental freedoms
not just that they are perverting and
will continue to pervert the media
so one of the most hilarious things that
the media really believe that their
mission extends only as far as the
nearest republican
they believe that the the republicans
are worthy of covering
in great detail and i've said for a long
time i don't mind that the media are
hyper critical of trump what i mind is
that the media
are hyper obsequious to democrats and
when it comes to democrats they carry
around a drool cup
when it comes to trump they carry around
a bat okay that you don't get to do that
and then pretend you're objective that's
nonsense if 90 of coverage of donald
trump is negative
and 99 of coverage of barack obama is
positive
you're doing it wrong as a so-called
objective journalist you say that you're
objective you're not objective
not in any way shape or form and the
the self-described heroism of these
folks is astonishing
i mean they believe that they are heroes
the democracy dies
in darkness crowd i'm not putting aside
you know the the opinion leaders
the people the self-congratulatory
opinion leaders over the lincoln project
people like max boot so max boot i just
have to put this tweet up because it's
so
absurd on his face he tweeted out win or
lose
never trumpers can hold their heads high
we made our best case wrote our most
coaching columns produced our most
convincing commercials
i know that i left it all out on the
field we all did the rest is up to
voters
it's like kevin from the office i am a
hero
that that's that's all these folks are
are people who
sit around in their coffee clutches and
talk about what heroes they are for
standing up to trump but
the problem is not max boot because who
cares about max boot i mean
captain fedora over there and by the way
his some of his books on like
military warfare are actually pretty
good it's sad what happened to max boot
but
putting aside max boot talking about the
so-called objective media
they're basically acknowledging where
they're going post-trump and the answer
is it's getting uglier it's getting
worse okay it's not going to get better
if you believe that the media are going
to get better at this
after the election you are sadly
mistaken we're going to go right back to
the era of barack obama when the only
scandal was a town suit and if you asked
barack obama a hard question it was
because you were a racist
jay rosen who teaches journalism at nyu
he tweeted out today today i don't mind
admitting that i'm mentally and
spiritually exhausted
nerves fried patience worn smile fake
soul damaged insights depleted and i'm
feeling like all the words have been
said
my wrist aches from doom scrolling may
risk
his wrist may ache from something else
i'm guessing my shock meter is busted
my mind won't reel that is captain
journalism over at nyu
meanwhile ben smith has a piece over the
new york times talking about what
happens
in the media if joe biden were to win
and the answer is they go right back to
being the partisan hacks that they were
before they are partisan hacks they're
not objective journalists
he says many leaders in news and media
have been holding their breaths for the
election
and planning everything from retirement
to significant shifts in strategy for
the months to come whoever wins
president trump after all succeeded in
making the old media great again in part
through his obsession with it
his riveting show allowed much of the
television news business in particular
to put off reckoning with the
technological shifts that have changed
all of our lives but now change is in
the air across a newspaper newscape that
has revolved
around the president oh weird so when
trump is president then the news
revolves around the president but when
barack obama or joe biden or any other
democrat is president
then the media cover everything else
everything else they're going to change
how they cover things so many in the
media have decided that they're retiring
their job here is done guys
their job here is done and newsrooms are
now declaring that they're going to move
openly in the direction
of the left-wing agenda according to ben
smith
he says many people are stepping down
the executive editor of the la times
norm pearlstein is looking to recruit a
successor by the end of the year
martin barron the executive editor of
the washington post just bought a house
out of town two posters said they
expected him to depart next year
the post spokeswoman christina karate
said he hadn't given notice yet but the
executive editor of the new york times
is on track to retire
in 2022. meanwhile jeff zucker of cnn
has signaled he's frustrated with warner
media
and there's speculation that he may
leave now here's the best thing okay
here's where it gets really good so
pearlstein who again is the executive
editor of the new york times
he says the new metrics for success in
media you ready the new metrics for
success in media might be different as
well
issues such as inclusiveness such as
being anti-racist
so that's the media openly telling you
where they're going they're an open
propaganda wing of the radical part
of the democratic party the most radical
part of the democratic party anti-racism
is code for ibrahmex kennedy
robin de angelo bullcrap that's what it
is code for it is code for you are a
racist if you oppose the socialistic
agenda
of ibram kendy and robin deangelo the
fascist socialist agenda of those people
if you oppose that
you're not anti-racist and that means
you're bad and so the way that we're
going to gauge media coverage and a
success is how anti-racism
it is also he says that we're going to
allow
all of the staff journalists who have
unionized to run the shop
in media so if you're worried about the
status of the mainstream media
watch as it destroys itself in perfect
but massaging obsequiousness to
democrats
pearlstein says the old top-down
newsroom management is a thing of the
past
he says consent of the government is
something you have to take pretty
seriously no you don't
not at a corporation are you insane you
think consent of the government matters
one
iota around here at daily wire i'm the
editor okay i'm the editor emeritus of
dailywire.com
you think if my people came to me and
they were like we're not anti-racist
enough we're upset about that you think
i'd be like oh i'm gonna listen to
everything that you have to say
in your stupid adult little brains you
think that's what i would do
since when has consent of the government
been a thing at a newspaper
what in the world wesley lowry a cbs
news correspondent who's been a voice
for more diverse and politically engaged
journalism said he'd already seen signs
of change
he said these big institutions very
rarely come out and announce a big
sweeping change
they say we're not changing and they
change even people who made a big deal
about how the rebels were wrong are now
conceding to the things
we all wanted wesley lowry by the way a
cbs news correspondent is a person who
says
that all journalism should be openly
partisan that you don't want false
fairness
we need open partisan journalism so if
biden is elected watch for more open
partisan journalism on behalf
of joe biden watch for attacks on your
fundamental rights
watch for attacks on the institutions of
the united states
watch by the way for an economy that is
going to stagnate
pretty quickly okay all of these things
are things that are likely to happen if
joe biden is elected so go out and vote
if you like the institutions
if you like the fact that on election
day we all get to exercise our rights
in freedom then maybe you should vote to
preserve those freedoms because in the
long run
the agenda of the democratic party does
not square with many of those
fundamental freedoms
and while you're voting be grateful that
you live in a country as wonderful as
the united states
and think about maybe why the united
states is so great and what we can do to
uphold that
what we can do to in president trump's
phrase make america great again alrighty
i'll be back here later today with two
additional hours of content also
we have programming all day long all day
long at dailywire.com
remember 25 percent off i'll let you use
the code election
when you when you get that membership
and you can hang out with us all day
watch the election returns come in
we are going to be marathoning it all
day so hang out with us
over at dailywire.com this is the ben
shapiro show
the ben shapiro show is produced by
colton haas executive producer jeremy
boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
production manager pavel wydowsky our
associate producers are nick sheehan and
rebecca doyle
the show is edited by adam scievent
audio is mixed by mike coromina
hair and makeup is by nico geneva the
ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production
copyright daily wire 20 20. you know the
matt wall show
it's not just another show about about
politics i think there are enough of
those
already out there we talk about culture
because culture drives
politics and it drives everything else
so my main focuses are
life family faith those are fundamental
and that's what this show is about
hope you'll give it a listen